everyone is also being mean right now to
bill gates
who's one of our good friends they're
being mean to him
because he doesn't want to share his
vaccine patent
with the developing world
well i mean
have you ever been to a restaurant
and you're eating the chicken wings and
you go
what is in this
sauce i've done this and the waiter
looks at you and goes
we could tell you what's the funny joke
do you know it
you don't know it oh if we told you we'd
have to kill you if we
tell ya we'd have to kill you
this is this guy's hot wing sauce
this is his secret sauce
this is his flavor of the month mango
habanero glaze sauce
and no it doesn't get bottled up without
his say-so
he could tell you but he'd have to kill
you
you think bill gates was sitting around
cooking up this batch
so that people out there could just take
it and
open up their own wing stands
we think not and and i understand it
because you imagine a hot wing sauce
imagine if it was a vaccine that could
potentially save the lives of
of millions of people that are literally
burning their bodies in the street right
now
you would still say hey that's my
mother's recipe
you can't take it let's read a little
bit of this bill gates under fire for
saying vaccine formula shouldn't be
shared with developing world
do you want to hear him defend himself
here yeah let's
hear him defend himself because we are
too critical of him
i have always believed this guy had no
intentions
except the best intentions for humanity
that's why he wanted to shoot a missile
of uh dust at the sun
and uh why he uh you know he went uh you
know white water rafting with
epstein but he is
just about saving lives there's been
some speculation that the changing
intellectual property rules
um and allowing these vaccines as you
say
the the the recipe for these vaccines to
be shared
would be helpful and do you think that
would be helpful
no why not well there's only so many
vaccine factories in the world
and people are very serious about the
safety of vaccines
and so moving something that had never
been done moving a vaccine from say a
uh a j factory into a factory in india
that it's novel it's only because of our
grants and our expertise that can happen
at
all the the thing that's holding things
back in this case
is not intellectual property there's not
like some idle vaccine factory
with regulatory approval that makes
magically safe vaccines
you've got to do the trials on these
things and every manufacturing process
has to be looked at in a in a very uh
careful way uh i'll answer the real
answer
play her question again i'm going to
answer his answer okay
there's been some speculation that the
changing intellectual property rules
um and and allowing these vaccines as
you say
the the the recipe for these vaccines to
be shared
would be helpful and do you think that
would be helpful
list listen
listen i don't even know
what you think you're asking me right
now
okay here's a reality
there are these things called vaccines
they're tough to make they're not made
in a magical factory in the sky
okay they're made for profit
in a factory where i walk around with a
hard hat
and i goose people gender unimportant i
just goose them
that's where they're gonna be made and
if you want one
you can spend a little coin okay
but other than that we're not gonna be
letting you
run around with our product all over the
developing world
we do that if somebody's pricking you in
sub-saharan africa
that is us okay
so let's be real clear about why i'm in
this business
it's to make a couple of bucks
you think tech is good money you think
finance is good money
you know it's good money the essence of
all life
that's what i've decided i got a little
bored
i got a little bored at microsoft where
do you work microsoft right yeah i got a
little bored there
okay so i decided my next business
venture would be
trying to control the essence of all
life
on this planet deciding how much of it
there is and where
it should happen okay so i'm not
interested in like
you know this isn't a potluck dinner
where everybody brings a vaccine
this isn't a firehouse where somebody
brings macaroni salad
somebody else you know brings a [ __ ]
lasagna
this is a vaccine party and it's at my
house
okay [ __ ] he seemed a little flustered
kind of giving that answer
he didn't look as comfortable as he
usually does giving that answer
why doesn't he host snl
what's with elon musk all the time get
gates uh to host snl
elon musk clearly wants the spotlight
let's not give it to him
let's get bill gates to host snl and
they could do a fun sketch
about bill gates explaining uh
to an indian peasant whose entire family
of 72 people
has just been burned alive in the street
why he can't share the vaccine patent
it'll be a laugh riot
i think so can't you see that sketch
aidy bryant and bo and yang dressed as
indian peasants
crawling across the floor okay
talking to bill gates about the vaccine
patent
i can and why not